Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn man als Reporterin vor Ort ist bei der EM 2022 und vor allem über das deutsche Team berichtet? Das wollen wir jetzt herausfinden in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 223. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das hier ist ein spielfreier Tag und dennoch bekommt ihr einen Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Warum ist dem so? Weil die liebe Jana Lange vom Sport-Informationsdienst SID sich Zeit für uns nimmt und uns mal erklären wird, was sie eigentlich so macht bei einem Turnier wie diesem. Deswegen sage ich hallo Jana. Sehr schön, dass du hier bist. Das freut mich wirklich sehr. Wir haben das vor der EM mal so vage angesprochen und jetzt hat es tatsächlich reingepasst. Ich will mal mit dir ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen blicken und die Hörerinnen und Hörer daran teilhaben lassen, wie eigentlich die Arbeit von Journalistinnen und Journalisten vor Ort bei einem solchen Turnier funktioniert. Du bist jetzt für den Sport-Informationsdienst dort, also für eine Agentur, die sich mit Sportnachrichten befasst, für all diejenigen, denen der SID nichts sagt oder auch SID, wie wir ihn manchmal abkürzen. Erzähl doch mal, wie sieht er denn aus, dein Alltag bei so einem Turnier?
Ja, also ich bin tatsächlich jetzt seit 19 Tagen hier, seit dem 3. Juli und es ist relativ ähnlich, der Tagesablauf. Also es ist auch ein bisschen täglich cool, ist das Moment hier, ist alles sehr streng vorgegeben von dem, was die deutsche Mannschaft treibt und da sie ja jetzt mitspielt und schön lange im Turnier bleibt, ja, ist es vom Tagesablauf immer recht ähnlich. Also bei mir ist es so, dass ich morgens meistens schon die ersten Texte und Meldungen produziere, dann gibt es mittags bzw. nachmittags, 13.45 Uhr Ortszeit, gibt es immer eine Pressekonferenz vom DFB mit Spielerin oder jemandem aus dem Betreuerstab. Genau, und dann wird danach auch noch mal ein bisschen das aufgearbeitet und ja, das ist alles streng vorgegeben vom Spielplan, dann gibt es am Tag vor dem Spiel gibt es dann noch mal eine Pressekonferenz und am Spieltag ist eh alles anders, dann arbeitet man vormittags ein bisschen und hat dann hinten raus ja dann das Spiel und die Nachbereitung in der Nacht so ein bisschen früh aufstehen, weitermachen. Also das sind immer so die Tage, wo der Schlaf am kürzesten kommt.
Die Spieltage dann ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Jetzt weiß ich, dass du ja auch schon in der Vorbereitung des Teams mit vor Ort zum Teil warst. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, also beim Spiel in der Schweiz, glaube ich, habe ich dich dort im Pressekonferenzraum gesehen. Also ich habe dich virtuell gesehen, ich war ja nicht da. Und ansonsten warst du aber auch häufiger zugeschaltet. Wie lange begleitest du denn jetzt dieses Team eigentlich schon ohne Pause?
Das war tatsächlich so ein bisschen punktuell, wie wir das gemacht haben mit der Vorbereitung. Da war ich nicht kontinuierlich dabei. Da war ich zum Beispiel beim Medientag in Herzogen auch vor Ort. Dann, wie gesagt, rund um die Generalprobe war ich dann auch noch mal vor Ort. Das haben wir so ein bisschen virtuell und vor Ort abgemixed. Der DFB hat ja recht viel auch virtuell angeboten, mit sehr vielen Presserunden im Vorfeld. Da habe ich dich auch sehen dürfen. Das war erstmals so in der Form, dass sie da echt viel zugänglich gemacht haben für Medien, die nicht die ganze Zeit vor Ort sein konnten. Das war sehr schön. Da konnte man schon sehr viel mitnehmen in der Zeit vorher. Von daher ist es kontinuierlich am Stück nicht viel länger als der 3. Juli. Aber im Vorfeld, immer punktuell auch schon mal rund um die Generalprobe und diesen Medien-Tag Mitte Juni bin ich dann quasi rund ums Team tätig gewesen.
Jetzt kennst du ja die Spielerinnen sehr gut. Du kennst alle Beteiligten sehr gut. Du machst das ja schon viel länger als ich. Wie schwierig ist es denn für dich, Themen zu finden? Also wenn es keine Skandale gibt, und da ist jetzt zumindest nichts bekannt, es gibt keine großen Aufreger zwischen den Spielen, wie schaffst du es da eben immer wieder neue Dinge zu verarbeiten? Nimmst du da auch Dinge, die du vielleicht in den Presserunden vor dem Turnier schon erfragt hast und verarbeitest die dann später in Artikel, in einzelne Porträts? Wie gehst du da heran?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich teilweise schon so, dass man vieles, was man sich vorher, wie man sagt, immer so schön in den Blog geholt hat, dass man das tatsächlich noch gut verwenden kann, wenn man weiß, wo man es hingeschrieben und archiviert hat. Das geht den anderen auch so. Da sprechen wir auch viel mit den anderen Kollegen drüber, dass wir teilweise so viel Input haben, dass wir gar nicht wissen, wohin mit unseren ganzen Geschichten. Klar, auch unser Arbeitstag ist begrenzt und wir können manchmal gar nicht so viel machen, wie wir gerne wollen, aber das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig, finde ich, mit den Themen, weil du allein durch die Personalien, die du ja aufschreiben kannst, um der Fußballöffentlichkeit in der Heimat die ein oder andere Spielerin zu präsentieren, die sie vielleicht noch nicht so gut kennen, geht super viel und übergreifende Themen. Ich sag mal, Anfang des Turniers ging es ja auch viel wieder um Equal Pay und Equal Play und all diese Themen. Da gibt es ja so viele in dieser Gesamtgemengelage, wo man immer wieder neue Schlaglichter werfen kann. Und auch ab und zu kann man auch, auch wenn ich jetzt sehr nah am deutschen Team arbeite, aber auch die internationalen Geschichten, wenn immer da was passiert. Dann hatten wir ja den Corona-Fall mit Lea Schüller. Das war natürlich auch dann manchmal ergibt sich einfach auch alles durch die Aktualität. Aber klar, wie du sagst, es gibt Skandale in der Form, gab es jetzt in der Form noch nicht. Aber ich fand es tatsächlich jetzt nicht so schwierig, immer neue Ansätze zu finden. Oder halt im Zweifel, wenn jetzt aktuell gar nicht irgendwas ins Auge sprang, konnte man wirklich viel über die Personalien machen. Also wie zum Beispiel die Personalie Merle Frohms, weil das ja auch so ein Thema ist, früher oder später musste man die Torwartfrage ja noch mal aufgreifen und beleuchten und solche Sachen, das kann man dann so ein bisschen sich von der Aktualität leiten lassen. Zum Beispiel nach dem Spiel gegen Spanien, wo sie sich ja auch dann auszeichnen konnte, so wurde das dann auch durch die Spiele und ja so ein bisschen vorgegeben, aber auch gleichzeitig durch, wer sitzt auf der Pressekonferenz, dann hast du natürlich auch mal schon so ein bisschen ein Drehbuch vorgegeben.
Das sie auch der DFB vorgibt, die wissen ja auch ganz genau, wen sie dahinsetzen.
Genau, wobei die auch Rücksprache mit uns halten. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, als würden die das komplett ohne mit uns zu sprechen entscheiden, von daher die nehmen da nach ihren Möglichkeiten auch Rücksicht auf das, was wir sinnvoll finden für unsere weitere Berichterstattung. Also das haben die schon auch im Blick. Aber es ist natürlich ein Tischtoch, an dem viele Leute ziehen. Und gerade das Fernsehen hat natürlich auch Bedürfnisse und kriegt dann im Zweifel vielleicht auch mal eher eine Spielerin, die die Print-Kollegen vielleicht auch haben wollten. Das ist aber, ich kann mich nicht beschweren. Also ich finde, das läuft eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Mit den Vergleichen zwischen dem Männerfußball und dem Frauenfußball, da muss man ja nicht immer gleich dieses Buch aufschlagen. Ich finde im Bereich der Berichterstattung, finde ich es dann aber dann doch auch auf eine besondere Art und Weise relevant. Deswegen ist es vielleicht auch ein Vorteil für jemanden wie dich, dass viele der Spielerinnen gar nicht so gut bekannt sind. Und man einfach so, also in Anführungszeichen einfach, aber man kann auch biografische Stücke machen. Einfach erklären, wo kommt diese Spielerin her? Was macht sie eigentlich sonst so? Denn die Spielerinnen haben ja auch noch etwas neben dem Fußball. Das ist ja auch anders als bei vielen Männern. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel über Leon Goretzka schreiben würde, dass er mal bei Bochum und Schalke gespielt hat, das wäre noch kein Artikel. Ich hab das Gefühl, im Frauenbereich kann man da noch mehr so Grundlagenarbeit ein bisschen leisten. Macht es das für dich dann auch einfacher im Vergleich zur Berichterstattung jetzt zum Beispiel zur Männernationalmannschaft?
Auf jeden Fall. Also das ist auch mit einer Seite, die ich am liebsten mag, weil ich tatsächlich auch gerne diese Portraits schreibe. Das ist tatsächlich so, wo ich sagen würde, das ist noch ein gravierender Unterschied zum Männerfußball, dass man da sehr oft bei den Männern das Gefühl hat, man hat eigentlich schon mal alles erzählt und muss krampfhaft so einen neuen interessanten Ansatz finden, damit nicht alle gerne vor dem Text sitzen und denken, okay, das hab ich alles schon dreimal gelesen. Von daher ist es in dem Fall natürlich ein Vorteil, dass man eventuell von einem Bekanntheitsgrad anderer Natur ausgehen kann und, wie du schon sagtest, viele Biografien ja einfach auch interessante und ungewöhnliche Aspekte bieten. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel über Tabea Wasmuth sprechen, die mit ihrer Promotion in Neuropsychologie, natürlich, das ist natürlich an sich schon spannend. Wirtschafts-Mathematik-Studentinnen Lena Lattwein, also das sind ja alles so Randaspekte, die der Durchschnittssport-Fan vielleicht noch gar nicht so auf dem Zettel hatte. Von daher ist es genau, wie du sagst, was das angeht natürlich ein bisschen einfacher, so den Dreh zu finden, wie man es spannend und interessant verkaufen kann. Und das sind auch die Sachen, wo man natürlich im Vorfeld des Turniers sich schon gut überlegen kann, wo setze ich da meine Schwerpunkte, mit wem unterhalte ich mich bei so einem Medientag, da mal ein bisschen ausgiebiger. Aber du hast natürlich auch gleichzeitig Spielerinnen vom Format wie eine Alex Popp oder eine Almut Schuld, von denen die Leute sicherlich schon mehr wissen. Aber bei Alex Popp ist es natürlich so, die hatte natürlich durch ihre Vorgeschichte mit der langen Knieverletzung und dann noch Corona in der Vorbereitung, gab es natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Dramatik und Dynamik. Deswegen lag die Geschichte natürlich auch auf der Hand. Der Name ist natürlich auch immer noch so ein Eyecatcher für die Redaktion, die dann sozusagen auf unsere Texte zugreifen und sagen, über Alex Popp lesen unsere Zeitungsleser bestimmt auch gerne. Für mich ist das immer noch ein großes Plus, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Stimmt, das habe ich gar nicht dazu erklärt. Also in der Agentur funktioniert so, ihr schreibt Artikel und die haben sich andere Redaktionen eingekauft und dann erscheint das in vielen verschiedenen Medien. Also du schreibst jetzt nicht exklusiv für ein Medium, sondern sehr viele Leute können das lesen. Bei diesen Dingen, die neben dem Fußball passieren, bei denen jetzt, wenn wir einfach beim deutschen Nationalteam bleiben, da bin ich immer so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen. Weil auf der einen Seite erlebe ich es so, dass die Spielerinnen da auch gerne und bereitwillig darüber reden. Der Theorie nach ist das ja aber eigentlich ein privater Bereich. Klar, Lena Latvijn hat ein 0,9er-Abi, glaube ich, gemacht, nennt man es dann. Also die hat einfach alle Punkte gesammelt, die man sammeln kann beim Abi. Unglaublich beeindruckend. Bei vielen Sportlern würde ich jetzt aber sagen, das ist ja eigentlich deren Privatsache. Wie gehst du denn damit um und wie erlebst du das, diese Zweitbiografien quasi zu schreiben, die wir ja aus gar nicht so tollen Gründen, aber die wir im Frauenfußball eben einfach noch haben? Denn sie müssen sich eben für die Zeit nach der Karriere ganz anders wappnen als die Männer. Siehst du da auch eine Problematik?
Ja, ansatzweise, aber im erster Linie sind die meisten, die meisten Spieler sind ja irgendwo auch stolz drauf, dass sie das als Spagat so gut hinbekommen. Und reden dann eigentlich auch gerne drüber, was so ihr Alltag neben dem Fußballgeschäft letztendlich so wieder ausschaut und was sie da so machen. Klar, es gibt dann die Grenzbereiche, wo man dann sagt, okay, Privatleben, Beziehungen und so weiter, das ist jetzt auch gar nicht so spannend für mich. Das interessiert andere Mediengattungen natürlich deutlich mehr, wie man ja auch während dieses Turniers hier und da mal sehen kann. Aber was zu dem beruflichen oder zweiten Berufsweg dann angeht, sind die meisten Spielerinnen, glaube ich, schon fein damit oder finden es sogar auch ganz spannend und betonen ja auch immer selber den Aspekt, dass sie sich das gar nicht vorstellen könnten, dieses wirklich komplett nur auf Fußball ausgerichtete Leben, dass ganz viele sagen, ich brauche das unbedingt als Ausgleich zum Leistungssport. Von daher ist der Bereich, finde ich, meistens, so kommt es mir jedenfalls vor bei den Spielerinnen schon okay. Es ist immer so ein bisschen auch eine Frage der Situation, finde ich. Also wenn Spielerinnen auf einer Pressekonferenz hier sitzen, dann wird die live gestreamt im Internet. Dann ist das natürlich irgendwie nochmal gefühlt eine andere Öffentlichkeit für sie wahrscheinlich, als wenn man jetzt mit ihnen bei einem Medientag in so einem großen Raum sitzt und dann sitzen da drei, vier Journalisten vor ihnen. Dann hat das mehr so ein bisschen Interviewcharakter vielleicht. Dann ist es natürlich nochmal eine andere Atmosphäre. Aber ich glaube, im Normalfall ist es schon so, wenn man sie über diese berufliche Ebene versucht, anzusprechen, dann sind die meisten schon okay damit und erzählen das meistens, glaube ich, auch ganz gern.
Ja, so war zumindest meine bisherige Erfahrung. Aber dann habe ich jetzt auch ein besseres Gefühl dafür, woher mein Unwohlsein kam, wenn ich jetzt, als ich war zum ersten Mal bei Pressekonferenzen, dann zugeschaltet digital. Und das ist ja auch eine Erfahrung, auch im Vergleich zum Männerfußball, da war ich jetzt auch zugeschaltet. Also ich bin jetzt einfach auf der Telefonliste des DFB oder auf der E-Mail-Liste und jetzt auf einmal läuft das alles, war ein bisschen Kampf, dahin zu kommen. Aber jetzt ist es erfreulicherweise so. Und wenn es bei der Männer-Nationalmannschaft so ist, du hast maximal eine Frage, du kannst auch gar nicht sicher sein, ob du drankommst, war es bei den Frauen so, dass man durchaus auch mehrere Fragen stellen konnte und auch mehr Zeit hatte. Und dann hatte ich eben, es hätte mich wahnsinnig viel interessiert. Und ich wusste aber nicht, ist das jetzt der richtige Rahmen? Also wir sind vor einem Turnier, das heißt, wir können noch nicht über Sportliche reden. Aber genau das, was du sagst, jetzt kann ich das besser ein bisschen für mich verorten. Das hatte sicherlich auch mit dem Platz zu tun. Aber das wird dir sicherlich auch so gehen, dass du diese Freiheiten, die man bei der Berichterstattung über die Frauenfußballerinnen hat, das war jetzt ein Pläonasmus, aber das macht es für dich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen einfacher, oder?
Ja, also ich bin natürlich jetzt schon vielleicht so ein bisschen betriebsblind, weil ich es tatsächlich einfach schon recht lange mache. Da ist es echt interessant zu hören, was du dann erzählst, wie das für dich wirkt. Weil wie gesagt, diese Atmosphäre, die kenn ich nicht anders. Und die hat sich meines Erachtens auch nicht groß verändert. Es ist jetzt natürlich tatsächlich einfach so, dass durch diese digitalen Gesprächsrunden teilweise mehr Leute zugeschaltet sind, als es sonst de facto waren. Weil man einfach, man musste halt vor Ort sein, wenn man mit den Betreffenden sprechen wollte. Und den Aufwand und das Investment, den Betreibenden natürlich, betreibt dann wirklich der harte Kern. Von daher allein dieser Weg, dass man das jetzt so machen kann, ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Öffentlichkeit. Und ja, also ich würde sagen, ich hab's jetzt bei den Männern tatsächlich länger nicht erlebt. Also da muss ich sagen, da sind meine Berührungspunkte zur Männernationalmannschaft etwas länger her. Deswegen würde bei mir der Vergleich so ein bisschen hinken. Ich kenn's halt eher noch aus der Zeit weit vor den virtuellen Presserunden. Aber da sind meine Berührungspunkte in erster Linie, oder meine Erlebnisse waren da schon auch so, dass da halt ein noch viel größerer Pool an Leuten ist. Dass, genau wie du sagst, dass man viel weniger Chance hat, Fragen zu stellen oder froh sein muss, wenn man einmal drankommt. Und dann hoffen muss, dass viele Kollegen irgendwie ähnliche Dinge wissen wollen, wie man selber. Und das schon, also dieser Punkt, dass man muss noch mehr über diese Personen erfahren, ist natürlich bei den Frauen auf jeden Fall deutlich ausgeprägter. Und dann ist es auch, glaube ich, für die Spielerinnen, die sind häufiger damit konfrontiert, dass sie auch mal Sachen wieder und wieder beantworten müssen, weil neue Kollegen dabei sind. Von daher ist da, glaube ich, auch das Verständnis und dieses Gefühl auch besser. Und aus meiner Sicht, wie gesagt, ich kenne es halt in erster Linie so. Und deswegen würde ich das eigentlich so unterschreiben, dass es schon eine Form von Freiheit ist, die man da als Journalistin spürt, weil man das Gefühl hat, man kann sich da recht gut bewegen, man kann fragen, was einem auf dem Herzen liegt. Und ja, auch sonst werden, auch wenn man mal eine Anfrage hat für ein Telefon-Interview oder so, das ist, glaube ich, bei den Frauen auch deutlich höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du das auch bekommst, wenn du es brauchst. Wenn du jetzt mal nicht an der Presserunde teilnehmen möchtest, sondern stattdessen lieber ein Telefon-Interview aus der Ferne machen willst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit deutlich höher, als ich mir das bei den Männern vorstelle.
Ja, und ich muss sagen, das verändert tatsächlich die ganze Atmosphäre. Also ich habe jetzt schon viele Männerpressekonferenzen ja auch gesehen, weil ich bei allen Turnieren mir die Pressekonferenz auch immer schon angeguckt habe. Also ich war auch schon ganz lange passiver Zuschauer und habe das durchaus auch bei den Frauen gemacht, wo es ging. Und bei den Männern ist es schon interessant, weil das folgt so einer kleinen Choreografie. Also die erste Frage hat früher immer Andreas Bergmann von der TBA gestellt. Keine Ahnung, was da der Deal war, ist ja auch nicht schlimm, da war ja... Dann gab es immer sehr früh eine Frage, ich will jetzt gar nicht die ganzen Kollegen-Namen nennen, weil ich will mich da auch nicht lustig drüber machen. Es ist nur interessant, weil es eine ganz andere Atmosphäre ist, weil die Fragen waren oft themengetrieben und zwar aktualitätsgetrieben. Also es war völlig klar, wenn Leon Goretzka da sitzt, dann wird er jetzt nach Robert Lewandowski gefragt und zwar dreimal. Nicht einmal, sondern dreimal, weil man hofft, dass er bei der dritten Antwort das eine Zitat bringt, was dann alle brauchen. Und genauso wird nach aktuellen Themen in der Bundesliga gefragt. Es geht viel mehr um solche Dinge und auch viel mehr um Zitate. Also mit auch durchaus manchen Wolken, die ich persönlich dann, das ist nicht meine Art des Journalismus, Tilo Kehrer danach zu fragen, was er darüber denkt, dass Leroy Sane mit einem angeblich 450 PS starken Auto zum Training gefahren ist. Aber das macht halt jeder, wie er es möchte. Und da fand ich den Unterschied aber wirklich interessant, weil bei den Männern, da konnte ich manchmal so grob vorhersagen, welches Zitat wäre denn jetzt gerne gewünscht gewesen oder welche Geschichte werden denn jetzt da geschrieben. Und bei den Frauen fand ich es interessant, dass dadurch, dass dann auch die Themen viel breiter waren, dass es auch weniger aktualitätsgetrieben war. Man könnte ja auch ganz viele Fragen zu Entwicklungen in der Bundesliga der Frauen stellen. Aber das scheint nicht so die Relevanz zu haben, weil es ja auch die Leserinnen, die Rezipientinnen der journalistischen Produkte sehr wahrscheinlich nicht so mitbekommen haben, wie sie die Entwicklung in der Bundesliga mitbekommen haben. Und deswegen braucht es jetzt gar nicht, dass wir irgendwie... Also der Theorie nach könnten wir ja jede Wolfsburgerin auf dem Podium fragen, was erwartet ihr euch denn jetzt von Jule Brandt? Und ihr habt ja irgendwie, kauft ihr nicht eigentlich alle Konkurrentinnen schwach und so weiter? Solche Fragen würden wir ja im Männerfußball stellen, machen wir aber bei den Frauen nicht. Und das finde ich schon eine interessante Erkenntnis zumindest.
Ja, das ist halt irgendwie tatsächlich einfach noch ein komplett anderes Business, wenn man so will. Es ist genau wie du sagst, das eine ist total themengetrieben und da wird quasi aus jedem noch so kleinen, ja, fitzechen Brisanz wird natürlich dann automatisch eine Dynamik. Und das ist in dem Bereich Frauenfußball tatsächlich nochmal eine ganz andere Hausnummer. Klar gibt es dann auch da Sachen, die ja mehr Brisanz haben oder auch so eine gewisse Aktualität haben, weil irgendwo ist was zu Equal Pay passiert. Klar spreche ich dann eine Spielerin aus dem Mannschaftsrat auch mal aktuell zu dem Thema an, weil wir sowieso beim SID eine Geschichte gemacht haben zu dem Thema. Dann ist es natürlich super, wenn ich dann nochmal aus berufendem Munde jemand aus dem Mannschaftsrat der deutschen Nationalmannschaft dazu hören kann. Das ist klar, das passiert auch, aber es passiert, wie du sagst, deutlich weniger und auf einem völlig anderen Niveau, wenn du mich fragst. Diese ganzen kleinen Nebenschauplätze und diese ganze Kausal Lewandowski hat ja im Prinzip das ganze Geschäft in seiner Absurdität auf die Spitze getrieben, wenn man mal ehrlich ist. Also sowas, die Auswüchse gibt es natürlich nicht. Und wenn es nach mir ginge, muss es die auch nicht geben, jemals, egal wie populär der Frauenfußball noch so wird. Aber ja, das ist tatsächlich schon ein sehr krasser Unterschied, wie du sagst.
Was würdest du denn als deine größten Herausforderungen bezeichnen, jetzt wenn du eben bei einem Turnier vor Ort bist, was ist das, was dich am meisten fordert?
Wenn ich jetzt mal speziell an dieses denke, ist mit die größte Herausforderung, sich hier nicht mit Corona anzustecken. Es hört ihr wahrscheinlich auch in der Heimat, dass es hier in England die Zahlen ja relativ hoch sind. Plus gibt es ja eigentlich gar keine Maskenpflicht mehr. Das heißt, selbst wenn du hier in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln aufhältst oder sobald du in Innenräumen bist, ist das eigentlich alles nicht mehr reguliert. Gott sei Dank ist es so ein bisschen so bei dem Turnier hier, dass die UEFA bei den Pressekonferenzräumen, in den Stadien zumindest sagt, hier bitte FFP2-Maske, aber das war auch ein Krampf, das Leuten zu verklickern, die meistens, also die deutschen Journalisten, ich will da jetzt gar nicht so blöd daherkommen, aber die deutschen Journalisten haben es dann überwiegend selbstverständlich gemacht, aber dann Journalisten von den von den gegnerischen Teams waren da ein bisschen anfangs ein bisschen freizügiger und das fand ich ein bisschen anstrengend, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil du einfach, also klar, jeder Journalist, der hier hinkommt, möchte dieses Turnier bestmöglich begleiten Ja, ich bin ja auch ein bisschen auf der Seite. Es war so ein bisschen mein Horrorszenario persönlich, dass ich hier hinkomme und innerhalb kurzer Zeit auf der Nase liege mit Corona. Gar nicht irgendwie, dass ich denke, dass es mir persönlich irgendwie übelst schlecht geht. Aber einfach das Gefühl zu haben, okay, jetzt muss ich auf dem Hotelzimmer liegen, während ich eigentlich hier bin, um journalistisch zu arbeiten. Das wär so, ja gerade mit diesem ein Jahr mehr Wartezeit auf das Turnier, wäre das halt einfach mein Worst-Case-Szenario gewesen. Und toi toi toi, ich klopf mal auf Holz. Danke schön. Bis jetzt alles gut gegangen. Wir sind dann natürlich quasi im Kollegenkreis, achten wieder auf uns gegenseitig. Und ja, also das Wetter hat super gut mitgespielt, dass man viel an der frischen Luft sitzen konnte und gewisse Situationen dann einfach meiden kann, ohne jetzt komplett paranoid zu werden. Aber jetzt sind wir halt schon fast drei Wochen hier. Und wir haben es alle in unserem Journalistenkreis wohl noch nicht bekommen. Jedenfalls habe ich nichts mitbekommen, dass irgendjemand raus wäre von den Leuten hier vor Ort. Ja, das war so mit einer der größten Herausforderungen. Aber wenn man so generell über Turniere spricht, ist es natürlich schon so, es ist so eine, ich sag mal, Daueranspannung, weil du halt tatsächlich einfach jeden Tag deine Texte schreibst. Und auch wenn du gerade nicht schreibst, machst du natürlich schon Gedanken über den nächsten Text sozusagen. Man hat das Gefühl, man ist die ganze Zeit so online im Kopf. Ja, dann hast du halt auch so Tage wie die Spieltage. Dann kommt der Schlaf natürlich zu kurz. Und das ist auch nicht so einfach, dann wieder quasi in den normalen Rhythmus zu kommen, weil das nächste Spiel steht ja quasi immer schon vor der Tür. Und nach dem Spiel ist meistens auch immer super viel einfach zu tun und zu erzählen und zu machen. Das ist mit so die größte Herausforderung. Ja, und das ist halt auch auf einer persönlichen Ebene. Klar, wenn man halt mehrere Wochen auf Dienstreise ist, ist das natürlich irgendwo auch immer so ein bisschen anstrengend, weil du bist halt nicht in deiner gewohnten Umgebung. Im Prinzip lebe ich jetzt quasi seit fast drei Wochen im Hotelzimmer und bewege mich hier halt in London-Brandford in einer sehr schönen Umgebung, muss ich sagen. Also da haben es andere Teams wahrscheinlich weitaus schlechter und deren Journalisten oder deren begleitenden Journalisten wahrscheinlich auch. Also da können wir uns echt wirklich nicht beklagen. Die Umgebung rund um das Stadion hier und die Mannschaftsunterkunft und das Pressekonferenzzentrum im Hotel. Das ist wirklich schön. Da kann man auch viel unternehmen. Da kann man sich auch mehrere Wochen gut wohlfühlen. Aber klar, es ist immer so ein bisschen, jeder Tag hat so ein bisschen was Redundantes. Du warst die ganze Zeit im gleichen Hotelzimmer auf und dann hatten wir letzte Woche ja auch das Spiel in Milton Keynes. Das war dann auch wieder, wie kommen wir da hin und so weiter. Dann bist du hier in einem Land, wo die auf der falschen Straßenseite fahren und so weiter.
Und wahrscheinlich will man ja nicht so gerne öffentlich fahren wegen der Corona-Gefahr.
Genau, wir haben es dann aber trotzdem gemacht. Hat auch ganz gut funktioniert. Aber auch das ist dann wieder so eine Art Anstrengung, weil du dann wieder was, ja, neue Herausforderungen meistern musst während Pandemie-Zeiten und so weiter. Ja, aber das ist gleichzeitig auch, du bist bei einem Turnier und du weißt ganz genau, es kommt viel zu selten vor, sozusagen. Und du weißt, dass es eine tolle Gelegenheit ist, vielen Menschen was über Frauenfußball zu erzählen und den Protagonistinnen näherzubringen. Von daher weiß man die ganze Zeit, wofür man es macht und dass man sich lange drauf gefreut hat. Von daher ist es ja mal auf hohem Niveau.
Und wie nimmst du die DFB-Verantwortlichen und auch die Spielerinnen wahr? Es wirkt immer alles sehr locker. Unheimlich harmonisch, fast schon zu harmonisch. Ich habe mich nicht getraut, die Frage zu stellen. In der letzten Pressekonferenz dachte ich, ob ich ihr die Frage stelle, ob es auch zu harmonisch sein kann. Aber dann dachte ich mir, da weiß ich ja schon, was ihr dazu sagen würdet. Deswegen habe ich es mir dann verkniffen. Ist auch keine gute Frage. Aber es wirkt sehr locker. Ist es denn in dem Teil des Umfelds, den wir ja nicht sehen, den du aber noch besser im Blick hast, ist es da auch so?
Überwiegend würde ich ja Ja sagen. Die Spielerinnen wirken schon locker. Ich meine, klar, sie haben jetzt genau die Hürde geschafft, die sie, glaube ich, schaffen mussten, um sich so zu fühlen, als könnten sie hinterher sagen, das Turnier war erfolgreich. Sonst hätten wir beim dritten Viertelfinal in Folge ganz andere Fragen stellen und kritisch hinterfragen müssen. Und jetzt mit dem Halbfinaleinzug bist du natürlich an einem Punkt, wo du eigentlich nur noch mehr gewinnen kannst. Ich nehme die Spielerinnen tatsächlich auch so wahr, wie du sagst. Die Bundestrainerinnen meistens auch. Wobei man ihr schon bis zum Viertelfinale, also ich habe vor dem Viertelfinale, konnten wir nochmal mit ihr sprechen, da hat man schon auch eine gewisse Anspannung gemerkt. Aber gepaart mit so einer wirklich, ja man kann den Leuten natürlich nur vor den Kopf kommen, aber eine sehr deutlich zur Sprache gebrachten Sicherheit. Da merkt man tatsächlich, dass sich da glaube ich was entwickelt hat über die letzte Zeit. Auch im Trainerteam. Und ja, dass das, was man von außen vielleicht schlecht beobachten konnte in Corona-Zeiten, weil man vieles nur aus der Distanz sehen konnte, dass sich da tatsächlich was gebildet hat, was man jetzt erst so richtig erkennen kann und was im Vorfeld, bis zur Generalprobe gegen die Schweiz, die ja schon so erfolgreich verlief, man das gar nicht so richtig greifen konnte. Aber die Spielerinnen, finde ich, kommen wirklich sehr professionell rüber, machen die meisten Medientermine eigentlich auch immer recht mit so einer positiven Einstellung und dass sie wissen, dass sie aus gutem Grund da sind und dass wir auch aus gutem Grund da sind. Von daher, ich finde das Zusammenspiel eigentlich sehr angenehm. Der einzige Punkt, wo es einmal so ein bisschen angespannt und, ja, so ein bisschen, nicht brenzlig, aber so ein bisschen, ja, in erster Linie angespannt wurde, war rund um die Corona-Infektion bei Lea Schüller. Da hat man schon gemerkt, es lief gut. Und dann kam auf einmal so ein bisschen wieder die Wagenburg-Mentalität. Aber das ist ja auch irgendwo verständlich in so einer Situation, weil das war glaube ich dann in intern schon auch ein echter Schreckmoment. Und dann denkt natürlich jeder erstmal so in erster Linie an sich. Und da hat man schon, da war auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Anspannung, zumindest so auf der medienverantwortlichen Ebene kurzfristig mal zu merken. Aber sonst ist es überwiegend professionell freundlich, bis locker und eigentlich auch sehr, sehr zuverlässig.
Ja, auch ja ein ganz interessantes Beispiel, diese Corona-Erkrankung. Das hatten wir jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren, haben wir diese Frage, dass ja die Corona-Erkrankung an sich ist was höchst Privates. Eigentlich geht es uns überhaupt nichts an, wie lange, ob es Symptome gibt, wie lange die Tests positiv sind. Weil es jetzt aber in diesem Rahmen als öffentliche Person Lehrerschüler stattfindet, ist es dann irgendwie doch relevant. Und das werden dann auch die Fragen danach gestellt. Und natürlich müssen das ja auch die ReporterInnen wissen, oder natürlich müssen sie das wissen, weiß ich gar nicht. Aber es ist für sie von einem dann doch auch öffentlichen Interesse, ab wann könnte sie sich denn wieder freitesten und so weiter. Da gibt es auch kein richtig und kein falsch. Das müssen auch die Verantwortlichen lösen. Aber das ist echt interessant, wie man durch Corona immer wieder in diesen Privatbereich reingreifen muss als Journalistin. Und ja, also in dem Fall ist es relativ eindeutig, weil es ein öffentliches Interesse daran gibt. Und weil auch jetzt sowohl Lehrerschüler als auch der DFB, man könnte ja auch nichts verheimlichen. In der Sekunde, wo sie irgendwann auf dem Trainingsplatz steht, ist klar, okay, gut, jetzt ist sie freigetestet. Und dann kannst du auch vorher schon so Zwischenstände abgeben. Und so hab ich mitbekommen, lief es ja auch. Zum Teil habe ich die ja auch mitbekommen, diese Zwischenstände. Aber deswegen finde ich es interessant, dass du das auch nochmal ansprichst. Das ist wirklich dieses Gespenst, was über diesem Turnier hängt. Und gleichzeitig auch eine Herausforderung, auch an die Berichterstattenden, wie man damit umgeht, finde ich.
Ja, sehe ich auch komplett genauso. Wobei, auch da muss man, glaube ich, für sich dann das richtige Verhältnis finden auf der einen Seite. Und ich glaube, wenn man dann sieht, dass der Verband selbst über seine Kanäle, wie jetzt zum Beispiel auf Instagram oder so, dann Bilder von Lea Schüller postet, wie sie dann im Teamhotel auf dem Balkon steht und winkt und so weiter, dann sieht man ja auch, dass der Umgang dann an sich relativ unverkrampft daherkommt. Lea Schüller postet dann selber was aus der Isolation und so weiter. Das spricht ja dann alles dafür, dass der Umgang jetzt nicht so hypersensibel ist, wie man es eventuell denken könnte, weil es nun mal einfach persönliche Gesundheit und damit auch so ein geschützter Raum ist. Aber ich glaube, da muss man halt so eine Gradwanderung mitmachen. Und in dem Fall, wie du sagst, sobald sie nicht auf dem Trainingsplatz ist, würden Ehefragen auftauchen. Bei so einem Turnier ist es natürlich dann einfach so ein bisschen im Brennglas. Andere Mannschaften sind ja noch viel schwerwiegender von diesem Problem betroffen. Ich habe jetzt bei den Schwedinnen mitbekommen, die haben halt so ein bisschen Eiertanz gemacht, glaube ich, was deren Infektionen anging. Und dann habe ich aber auch gedacht, ja, ist ja eigentlich okay. Also das kann ja jeder Verband so entscheiden, wie er das möchte. Und wenn sie nicht sofort preisgeben wollen, wer jetzt wie in welcher Form positiv getestet wurde, ist das ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Also da will ich jetzt aus meiner persönlichen journalistischen Sicht auch nicht sagen, ich bestehe darauf, dass ihr mich jetzt darüber informiert, welche Namen und so weiter. Ich finde, das ist dann halt so ein Bereich, da muss man halt so ein bisschen Rücksicht nehmen aus Reporter-Sicht. Und das fand ich ganz interessant, dass der Verband da so ein bisschen anders mit umgegangen ist. Aber da bin ich natürlich auch überhaupt nicht nah genug dran, um zu wissen, was genau und warum genau sie das so gemacht haben. War mir jetzt nur aufgefallen, dass das da quasi irgendwie, das gefühlt in den schwedischen Medien so ein bisschen wie so Live-Ticker dann kam. Ernsthaft, waren es positive Schnelltests und man wusste gar nicht von wem, dann popten auf immer irgendwelche Namen auf. Ja, das fand ich ganz interessant so als Kontrast.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch etwas, was zeigt, wie dann auch die einzelnen Verbände diese Aufmerksamkeit lenken können. Denn bei Schweden war die Diskussion viel größer darum, wen hat es erwischt, hat es Anderson jetzt auch getroffen, der Trainer möchte nicht darauf antworten, was bedeutet das jetzt. Es war viel größeres Aufhebens als jetzt im Vergleich bei Deutschland. Lea Schöller ist positiv, sonst hat es keinen erwischt. Und dann war das Thema durch, weil die Geschichte, die man schreiben konnte, die war ja auch da, die war nämlich so, jetzt kommt Alex Popp, Mensch, das könnte ja auch jetzt eine richtig gute Geschichte werden. Und wie gut, dass man diesen breiten Kader hat und so weiter. Also du hattest auch eine Anschlussberichterstattung dann durch diese Information. Und genau, man kann es nicht werten, das muss jeder Verband machen, wie er es möchte. Aber den Kontrast fand ich wirklich auch sehr interessant. Ich habe noch eine letzte Frage an dich, Jana. Das ist auch so eine grundsätzlichere Frage. Du hast ja auch schon selber gesagt, dass jetzt bei diesem Turnier es ja auch darum geht, Werbung zu machen oder zumindest Informationen zu bereiten. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob man dich als Werbebrutschafterin, sollte man das glaube ich nicht bezeichnen, das wäre auch falsch. Es sollen ja auch kritische Themen angesprochen zu werden. Aber dennoch, worauf ich hinaus möchte, ist, es gibt eine sehr positive Stimmung. Das Team spielt einen mitreißenden Spielstil und ist auch sehr oder relativ mitreißend, finde ich, in der Kommunikation nach außen. Und jetzt stehst du dann ja als Reporterin, genauso wie ich ja auch mit meinen Formaten, wir stehen ja so an einer Schnittstelle. Auf der einen Seite sollte man sich nicht zu sehr selbst mitreißen lassen, aber man sollte ja auch transportieren. Das, was da passiert, auch neben dem Platz und auch auf dem Platz, das hat eben auch emotionale Komponenten und da sieht man eben miteinander feiernde Spielerinnen und so weiter. Wie versuchst du da den richtigen Grad zu treffen?
Ich glaube, dass das ein bisschen bei mir auch Erfahrungssache ist, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Wenn man schon einige Turniere gesehen hat und auch einfach dadurch weiß, wie schnell sich Dinge ändern können, also würde ich jetzt behaupten, hat man automatisch so eine gewisse Distanz eingebaut. Die jüngere Vergangenheit hat es ja auch immer wieder gezeigt. Da lief es auch schon mal gut und da lief es schon wieder plötzlich schlecht. Und K.O.-Spiel ist sowieso K.O.-Spiel. Von daher, ich habe da manchmal gar nicht so die Zeit, mich so wirklich mitreißen zu lassen, weil du natürlich vom Kopf her so eine ganz andere Wahrnehmung einfach grundsätzlich hast, weil alles, was da passiert, wird ja quasi intern von dir die ganze Zeit bewertet. Du versuchst es zu analysieren, du versuchst es in Worte zu packen. Ich habe so das Gefühl, ich habe ja diesen Blick, ich sitze vorm Fernseher oder im Stadion und genieße ein Fußballspiel, den habe ich da in den Momenten ja gar nicht. Von daher, das ist, glaube ich, so eine, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich über den Dingen stehe. Klar hat man Emotionen, wenn man Dinge sieht und da sich Szenen abspielen, wo man sagt, das hat mir jetzt echt gut gefallen, wie Lena Oberdorf da diesen Zweikampf geführt hat und sich dann selber dafür feiert oder so. Aber ich glaube, dass das einfach so eine Berufskrankheit ist, dass du automatisch so einen Filter mit drin hast, der dich so ein Stück weit davon abhebt. Aber gleichzeitig ist es ja auch die Aufgabe, das mitzutransportieren, wie du eben gesagt hast, dass da Dinge passieren, die was auslösen. Zu sehen, was es auch zu Hause auslöst, im Sinne von wie viele Leute konsumieren das an den Bildschirmen. Für mich hat es ja auch noch eine direkte Relevanz, weil wir merken, wie stark unsere Inhalte nachgefragt sind. Wir sehen ja auch, wie viel andere Medien mittlerweile zu dem Thema Frauenfußball oder dieser EM speziell publizieren. Das ist für uns natürlich auch immer wieder ein Ansporn, mehr zu machen und mehr anzubieten und zu gucken, wie kommt das an, wenn wir hier was anbieten und hier was daneben stellen und uns selber weiterentwickeln, unser Produkt erweitern, erweitern, erweitern. Das ist halt super spannend. Dann kann man sich auf der Ebene mitreißen lassen, wenn man so will, weil man sieht, was das insgesamt für eine Dynamik entwickelt. Aber klar, grundsätzlich ist es für mich angenehmer, im Stadion zu sitzen und eine Mannschaft zu sehen, die Fußball spielt, der was aussagt, der eine klare Handschrift trägt und in dem Fall von der deutschen Mannschaft auch taktisch flexibel aussieht. Und unterschiedliche Gegner werden mit unterschiedlichen Mitteln bespielt. Das sind natürlich alles Sachen, die man schon spannend finden darf, glaube ich. Das ist, glaube ich, unbenommen auch für vermeintlich neutrale Beobachter oder Journalisten, die sich ja trotzdem irgendwo freuen, wenn sie erfolgreichen und erfrischenden Fußball sehen.
Die macht die Arbeit leichter, wenn man was hat, was man beschreiben kann.
Genau, gestern war es nicht ganz so leicht, weil es ein bisschen viel hin und her gab. Und man quasi bis zur 90. Minute noch damit rechnen konnte oder musste, dass man sozusagen mehrere Spielausgänge vorbereiten muss. Das ist natürlich die Krux von Agenturjournalisten, die mit dem Abpfiff ein fertiges Produkt anliefern sollen. Aber grundsätzlich hast du vollkommen recht.
Ja, vielleicht ist das auch nochmal ein leichter Unterschied in der Perspektive. Mir ist das eben nur an mir persönlich aufgefallen, dass ich am Beginn der Sendungen manchmal richtig... Also da habe ich quasi noch eine emotionale Angestecktheit. Und jetzt nicht so, ich bin hier nicht der größte Deutschland-Fan. Aber ich habe versucht, quasi die Begeisterung zu transportieren. Und dachte mir dann, ist ja interessant, wann habe ich denn das zuletzt bei einem Männerspiel gemacht? Da hatte ich allerdings auch wirklich schon lange keine solche Begeisterung mehr. Aber deswegen habe ich so angefangen, das zu hinterfragen. Ist das überhaupt richtig oder sollte ich nicht viel nüchterner starten? Andererseits ist es aber auch schwierig, wenn du 20 Minuten nach Abpfiff Deutschland gegen Österreich anfängst zu sprechen über dieses Spiel, dann kannst du jetzt auch nicht so... Also da müsste man sich verstellen, um quasi komplett nüchtern anzufangen. Also Viertelfinale ist vorbei, 2 zu 0 Deutschland, war eine enge Nummer. Jetzt wollen wir das mal ganz genau analysieren. Hallo, hier sind meine Gäste. Ich verstehe, woher da meine Energie kommt, aber mir ist es an mir selber aufgefallen. Und vielleicht ist das dann aber auch ein Unterschied in der Medienform. Der geschriebenen Text, da ist ja selbst der szenische und emotionale Einstieg nüchterner, weil er ja quasi erstmal im Kopf übersetzt werden muss, das Rezipienten, anders als eben im akustischen Bereich.
Aber die Beobachtung, die du da hast, dass es so kurz nach Abpfiff und so, dass das dann noch schon emotional wirkt, das ist definitiv auch so. Also ich glaube, viele von uns sind auf mehreren Ebenen nach den Spielen auch schon noch irgendwie, haben noch höheren Blutdruck und ich hab das ganz oft so, dass wenn ich vom Spiel hier nach Hause gehe, nach Hause sag ich schon, ins Hotels zurückgehe, ja, es ist schon eine lange Zeit, hauptsächlich, genau. Dann reflektiert man quasi noch unterwegs oder unterhält sich drüber und so. Dann merkt man tatsächlich auch, dass da noch, ja, viel mehr oder viel weniger Distanz zum Geschehen sozusagen ist. Das muss ich dann in dem Sinne auch noch so ein bisschen abarbeiten. Also so ein Spiel, das was auslöst, das ist definitiv hier auch so. Und gerade wenn man im Stadion dann nochmal sitzt und dann auch die sehr, was ich gar nicht erwähnt habe, dass das mit den Zuschauern hier echt bis jetzt sehr, sehr, ja, schön und atmosphärisch tatsächlich auch mitreißend ist, das ist ja auch nochmal so ein Faktor. Das bin ich jetzt aus dem Alltag, sag ich mal, wenn ich beim WM-Quali spiele, in Erfurt oder so, sitze vor 6000 Zuschauern, ist das natürlich auch ein ganz anderes emotionales Empfinden, als wenn ich jetzt hier sitze und da sitzen verrückte Österreicher und verrückte Dänen und verrückte deutsche Fans und es ist echt ziemlich laut. Das macht ja auch nochmal was mit dir. Also zumindest geht mir das so und ich glaube, viele KollegInnen haben mir auch berichtet, dass sie nach diesen Spielen auch meistens immer irgendwie so ein bisschen Zeit brauchen, um so ein bisschen runterzukommen.
Ja, ich meine, das macht ja auch den Kick des Berufs aus, vor Ort im Stadion zu sein, das ist wahnsinnig laut. Du musst an dieser Stätte aber dann analytisch und schnell und präzise arbeiten. Das fand ich immer, immer wenn ich im Stadion mal auf einer Presse-Tribüne bin, das gibt mir einen ganz besonderen Kick, aber du schlägst auch definitiv nicht sofort ein, wenn du dich dann ins Bett legst. Dieses Adrenalin, das muss dann irgendwie auch erstmal wieder abgebaut werden. Und vielleicht ist das ja der Grund, warum es diese klassischen Zwei-Takt gibt im Berichterstatten von Spielen. Es gibt erstmal den Spielbericht und dann am nächsten Tag, meist hat sich ein bisschen durch online geändert, gibt es dann den Nachdreh, wo man dann versucht, die größere Geschichte zu machen oder den anderen Blickwinkel. Und die werden ja auch immer in einer ganz anderen Ansprache gehalten. Vielleicht kommt es auch daher, das ist einfach eine Reflektion. Dessen ist, wie es halt auch die Berichterstattenden selber erleben. Im Stadion und dann am Tag danach. Jana, das hat große Freude gemacht. Ehrlich gesagt könnte ich noch zwei Stunden mit dir weiterreden. Aber du sollst unbedingt auch noch ein bisschen Feierabend haben, wenn du denn überhaupt einen hast. Ich danke dir ganz, ganz herzlich, dass du dir so viel Zeit genommen hast. Und ich möchte alle Hörerinnen und Hörer dazu aufrufen, dir zu folgen. Man kann dir bei Twitter folgen als. Jeweils ausgeschrieben. Ich werde beides in den Show notes verlinken. Jana, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk.
Ja, ich danke dir für die Einladung. Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, wie immer.
Das freut mich zu hören. Und dann wünsche ich dir, dass du gesund bleibst. Bitte auch noch für die restlichen Tage jetzt dann. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Es geht dann bald weiter hier mit den Rasenfunk-Kurzpässen dann zu den Halbfinalspielen. Und wir haben auch noch was für die spielfreien Tage vorm Finale geplant. Also bleibt dran im Rasenfunk. Bleibt auch gesund. Bitte genießt den Sommer. Und wenn ihr mögt, dieses Turnier. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 224. Macht's gut.